the week after this election senior
editor of Think Progress Ned reznikov
and a screed online about his
unfortunate experiences with his
neighborhood plumber here is the
harrowing story as quoted by roving
journalist Michael Tracy he said quote I
wanted to share an experience from
earlier today this afternoon I had a
plumber over to my apartment to fix a
clogged drain he was a perfectly nice
guy and a consummate professional but he
was also a middle-aged white man with a
southern accent who seemed unperturbed
by this week's news and while I had him
in the apartment I couldn't stop
thinking about whether he had voted
Trump whether he knew my last name is
Jewish and how that knowledge might
change the interaction we were having
inside my own home I have no real reason
to believe he was a trump supporter or
an anti-semite but in my uncertainty I
couldn't shake the sense of potential
danger this is real folks I was rattled
for some time after he left I'm very
privileged insofar as this sense of
danger is unfamiliar to me and I know I
feel it much less acutely and a lot of
other people right now I'm still a
straight white guy who can phenotypic
phenotype eclis if you know typically
pass for Gentile plus my first name is
pretty waspey this is Ned Resnick off
writing the day after the election or
two days but today was a reminder that
unambiguous social interactions now feel
unsafe and unpredictable in a way they
never did before and even if Trump is
gone in four years I don't expect to
ever reclaim that feeling of security
that's just one more thing you voted for
if you voted for him okay then certain
radical leftists constantly attribute
motives to random people without knowing
those people Plummers it turns out don't
want to murder you just because they are
plumbers it turns out many plumbers are
even Democrats people of southern
accents are not out to murder Jews
unmask if you feel like you're living in
near Nazi Germany because a random
plumber came to your house at your
request to fix your shower and then was
polite but had a different accent and
different profession than you you might
be a political hypochondriac well stop
hyperventilating and get out a bit more
but the bubble only grows because people
only associate with people with whom
they agree particularly on the Left
conservatives were confronted with
leftists ideas and leftist personally on
a pretty regular basis there's only one
conservative cable news source Fox News
there's only one major conservative
national news publication The Wall
Street Journal and even there the
port Oriole side of the wall street
journal' leans left hollywood the
university's ESPN dominated by the left
conservatives can't escape leftism
leftist can escape conservatives so when
their bubble is punctured they freak out
it's why leftists are far more likely to
defend someone on facebook for their
politics than people are on the right
this sort of paranoia it means it's
going to be kind of difficult to live
together and if you can't hire somebody
to unclog your toilet because you're
afraid they're secretly a brown shirt
it's gonna make it kind of tough to
share a political system maybe leftist
ought to take a step back and recognize
the people with whom they disagree or
people they don't even know aren't the
awful evil villains they picture in
their heads i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show alrighty so much to get
to today we are back yay we're back and
this is gonna be an exciting year we
have lots of plans here at the ben
shapiro show lots of new surprises
lurking around every corner but first we
have to say hello to our advertisers
texture comm so if you're somebody who's
addicted to magazines or even reading a
just individual magazine articles
texture comm is the best so texture comm
is a service that allows you to pick and
choose from various different magazines
and subscribe basically to a bunch of
magazines at the same time and check out
their archives it's normally $9.99 a
month and you get access to over 200
magazines if you sign up right now at
texture comm slash Ben you get a 14-day
free trial so you can check it out see
if you like it and they have all of the
kind of top magazines and everything
from sports to news they have everything
from People magazine for you or your
wife to Time magazine to Reader's Digest
my wife is a big Reader's Digest fan to
Entertainment Weekly and and if you feel
like learning the 1 million new sex
positions they've Cosmo as well so they
have lots of different magazines that
you can access over at texture comm and
it is a great service if you're addicted
to information like I am texture comm is
the place to go texture calm / bed my
wife loves it I love it I'm a big fan of
the service ok so we come back and on
the day we come back naturally the big
story is Hollywood because what would a
day be without Hollywood celebrities
telling us what to think and what to
believe see after that election we're 60
some-odd million Americans said that
they really didn't care what how
thought Hollywood when all kanye west
i'ma let you finish we they basically
said they said we're gonna lecture you
and we said no no and they sound let you
finish but here's our lecture and then
they proceeded to lecture us so we had
just celebrity after celebrity at the
DNC and celebrity ad after celebrity ad
during the election cycle and now we've
had celebrity ads directed at electors
and we've had celebrity ads directed at
the press and we've had celebrity as
directed at everything but the child
molesters in Hollywood but you know they
but they are still not tired of
lecturing us because obviously if they
have a forum then they must lecture well
last night was the Golden Globes
first thing to point out about the
Golden Globes everyone always says the
day after the Golden Globes were the
Oscars God now that show was awful I've
been alive for 32 years 33 next week and
or I've been at least out of the womb
for that amount of time and in that
amount of time that I have been sentient
I will say that I have never gone to the
office of the day after one of these big
Hollywood events and people go WOW the
Oscars was great last night wasn't it no
one has ever said that so last night's
Golden Globes was indeed atrocious but
they're all atrocious because it's a
bunch of Hollywood celebrities
celebrating each other and telling each
other how wonderful they are and then
we're all annoyed because we think that
they're not that wonderful but we go and
pay money to see them anyway and then we
watch them on TV congratulating each
other and then were like god those
elitists and then we turn on our TV to
watch the elitists congratulate each
other okay so it's a little hypocritical
the whole exercise but I do think that
conservatives have a reason to be
annoyed when these events are infused
with politics and there are two reasons
for that one is Hollywood is supposed to
be our face to the rest of the world and
was during the 30s 40s 50s it was sort
of the American face to the rest of the
world what we presented to the rest of
the world as America came out of
Hollywood and still globally what people
think what America is they think of
product from Hollywood because most
foreigners have not been to the United
States and so if they think of country
America they tend to think of some movie
that was made about country amiracle or
a TV show about country America if they
see something about Texas they're more
likely to know Texas from a movie like
hell or high water than they are from
having visited Texas so we all have sort
of a stake in the image that Hollywood
projects of what America is and when
Hollywood skews solely to one side I
think we have a right to be a little
angry and Hollywood is very insular
Hollywood is not just insular Hollywood
does
against conservatives to prevent that
alternative viewpoint from coming out I
wrote a book about this called primetime
propaganda and I went basically
undercover and talked to a bunch of top
Hollywood producers and they admitted
openly to me on tape that yes they
discriminate against conservatives and
yes they biased their programming to the
left they thought I was a member of the
left because my last name is Shapiro and
I was wearing a Harvard Law baseball cap
so they figured Harvard Law grad with
the Jewish last name got to be a lab and
obviously I wasn't but yes there's
discrimination in Hollywood and that is
a reason for conservatives to be upset
that's reason number one reason number
two is that there used to be in the
United States this idea that yeah there
was politics and yeah there was
entertainment but entertainment was for
lack of a better term to use the leftist
term entertainment was sort of a safe
space and when you went to the office
the day after the world's here as you
could talk about the World Series
without talking politics when you watch
the football game you could have over
your friends on the other side of the
political aisle and you could have fun
talking about sports without having to
worry about politics when you went you
saw a movie when you watch the season of
Game of Thrones you could watch a season
of Game of Thrones and not have to be
bothered with whether a head that was on
a pike in season one was actually left
over ahead of george w bush because the
producers didn't like george w bush by
the way that actually happened in game
in season one of game of thrones a show
that i really enjoy so it's when
americans feel like their common spaces
are being ripped away from them when i
feel like i can't have a conversation
with someone on the left about Game of
Thrones because they're gonna start
lecturing me about Trump I watch
Entertainment to get away from that I do
it for a living right there's a reason I
don't even watch house of cards I don't
like watching political TV shows because
I think that I do politics as a day job
when I watch a TV show I want to be lost
in the escapism of it if there's a
message I want it to be subtle let me
tease it out myself I don't need to be
hit over the head with the unsubtle of
political musings of a bunch of 105 IQ
actors it's not something I'm into so
people have a reason to be upset when
they turn on the Golden Globes and
you're watching because your wife wants
to see all the pretty dresses or because
you want to see whether that TV show you
liked is gonna get any awards it's very
annoying to be slapped in the face with
by the way you're a bad person we're
gonna sit here and tell you're a bit as
we consume your product you're gonna
tell me I'm a bad person
we're the ones who watch your shows
we're the ones who put the twenty
million dollars in your pocket okay so
virtually every virtually every
presenter
tonight felt the need to mouth off about
Donald Trump this happened over and over
and just to give you an idea Jimmy
Fallon led off by targeting Donald Trump
this is clip six this is the Golden
Globes one of the few places left where
America still honors the popular vote
but Game of Thrones is nominated tonight
I agree well the show has so many plot
twists and shocking moments a lot of
people have wondered what it would've
been like if King Joffrey had lived well
in 12 days we're gonna find out and you
might remember Manchester by the seat
for being the only thing from 2016 that
was more depressing than 2016 the film
Florence Foster Jenkins has nominated
the character the character has been
dubbed the world's worst opera singer
and even she turned down performing at
Donald Trump's inauguration it's a tough
to book except today of course there's
always the ballots for tonight's Golden
Globes were carefully tabulated by the
accounting firm of Ernst & Young and
Putin okay so again joke after joke
all of them lame and people who are
watching at home they might think okay
well where were you guys you can make a
single joke about Obama for eight years
and in fact Obama sent a letter to all
the celebrities that I think won in
their swag bag at the Golden Globes and
it wasn't really I mean that's not a
joke I'm pretty sure that he wrote a
letter that went to all of the various
celebrities I know he had a big
celebrity event on Friday night he sent
a letter to all of them they party until
four o'clock in the morning that was the
first time that anybody at the White
House had been awake to take a 3 a.m.
phone call is when they were partying
with the celebrities not with Benghazi
but with the celebrities but that wasn't
alright it see of Hugh Laurie for some
reason dr. house was there and using the
night manager he's good actor doctor dr.
house but he was there targeting Donald
Trump as well I suppose made more
amazing by the fact that I'll be able to
say I won this at the last ever Golden
Globes
[Music]
I don't I don't mean to be gloomy it's
just that it has the words Hollywood
foreign and press in the title I just
don't know what I also think that to
some Republicans even the word
Association is slightly sketchy
okay first of all folks on the Left
should not rip on freedom of association
since its folks on the Left who want to
use government to cram down their rules
on religious communities but all of this
was just prelude to Meryl Streep's a
Meryl Streep is the Great Goddess if
Hollywood everyone worships at the altar
of Meryl Streep I've never been a
particularly big Meryl Streep fan I
think early in her career she was really
good and then later in her career she's
gotten very mannered and you can see the
gears turning all the time and you're
always kind of watching going wow she's
really good at crying you know you never
get some point we're like wow I really
feel emotionally affected by her tears
it's always like wow she was great when
she cried wasn't she that was really
awesome in any case not a critique of
Meryl Streep's acting skills as much as
a critique of what she said so last
night she she does this speech and her
entire speech it's a Lifetime
Achievement Award and it took a lifetime
for her to give the speech which he goes
up there with cue cards and she rips on
Donald Trump for basically about three
and a half minutes four minutes and we
will go through it because I think it is
important to note why Americans are
angry at this note let me say she has
every right to do this she has every
right to do this to free country I don't
think that anybody should be SuperDuper
crazy upset about the fact that an
actress in lefty Hollywood gave a lefty
Hollywood address to a bunch of other
Hollywood lefties I think it's absurd
that the left went what wouldn't act of
heroism
what heroines it's always amazing for
the left heroism amounts to saying stuff
they agree with a normally heroism is
bravery in the face of adversity that's
a pretty good general definition in
order for that to happen there needs to
be some adversity there's not a lot of
adversity in a Hollywood crowd of people
precisely two of whom in that entire
crowd voted for Trump is like Vince
Vaughn and Mel Gibson right that's it
the entire crowd but but she obviously
is the bravest woman who ever lived
because she said something in front of a
bunch of other Hollywood celebrities
while wearing a $12,000 gown and having
her hair done and making lots of money
to be in movies like Florence Foster
Jenkins which no one have ever seen but
we'll go through all of that in just a
moment first we have to say hello to
advertisers at DST LD so if you need
jeans and jeans are your thing I wear
jeans pretty much every day and jeans
are extraordinarily expensive you need
to go to DST LD calm right now
the SDS o LD they they have luxury gray
denim starting in 75 bucks the jeans are
really good they're really comfortable
and they are really quality they last
you can wash them a lot I've have worn
my jeans many a time and they are
they're very comfortable they look good
my wife tells me I just looked
phenomenal in them of course that could
be just trying her try and get access to
the checkbook but I have no way of
telling so I'll take credit for work but
the genes themselves are really
comfortable they look really good and so
and they are they're much cheaper than
they would be if you went to a top-line
store 75 bucks at DST LD com they
shipped you directly they guarantee the
fit and if they don't fit they'll send
you a new pair until they are perfect
and they will be a staple in your closet
for years
DST LD calm distilled calm / pen you go
to slash Bend get 10 bucks off so that
means you get it for 65 bucks a pair of
jeans instead of 75 bucks
okay so play a little bit of Meryl
Streep speech and then we'll go and then
we'll break for a second so here is
Meryl Streep last night at the Golden
Globes going off Thank You Hollywood
Foreign Press just to pick up on you
what Hugh Laurie said you and all of us
in this room really belonged to the most
vilified segments in American society
right now think about it Hollywood
foreigners and the press whenever they
have the cutaway shots of other adoring
actors who they all hate each other they
hate each other and they all go to the
shots I love Meryl god I wish you were
dead I mean that's what all the faces
are always in the audience at these at
these events but Hugh Laurie has to be
steaming it was my joke first or it was
my joke first and but in any case she
goes on like this first of all quick
note and then we'll go to break that is
that that she says there that Hollywood
Florence and the press are the most
vilified people in America they spent
the entire night ripping on the people
who live in flyover country it's been
the entire night ripping
on the rubes who voted for Donald Trump
or didn't vote for Hillary Clinton
the entire night yes you're right I'm
sure that you are so vilified people
hate you so much Meryl Streep what a
victim you are all poor baby and the
idea the press is vilified yeah the
press is vilified I'm part of the press
it turns out that a lot of the time we
deserve the vilification sometimes we
get it wrong sometimes we fib sometimes
we lie and we deserve that but the idea
that being vilified is the end of the
world
look you guys vilify Trump at every
opportunity so if we're gonna talk just
if you're gonna dish it out you got to
take it a little bit and this whole war
victims because people are mean to us
routine gets a little old when everybody
in this room could buy the entire rest
of America three times over it's a
little bit galling to hear these these
these limousine socialists talking about
how vilified they are how rough it is
for them okay well we have to break
they're on Facebook and YouTube but we
will continue over at the Daily wire and
you can and you can subscribe right now
for eight bucks a month at Daily wire
comms becoming an annual subscriber I
think we're in the final days of our
deal where we send out signed copies of
my novel true allegiance and we have a
bureau store coming up I think the
Shapiro store Clavin store those are
both coming you can get access to the
rest of the podcast visually plus you
can become part of the mailbag we have
lots of goodies coming if you become a
member
eight bucks a month will get you access
to daily wire.com so go over there and
subscribe right now or listen to the
rest of the podcast later on iTunes or
SoundCloud or do both preferably but
check us out we are the largest
conservative podcast in the United
States
you